CHILDREN AS A POLITICAL WEAPON.
WE WILL TELL YOU ALL ABOUT IT.
ALSO TONIGHT, BIG NEWS FROM THE
U.S. SUPREME COURT.
LIBERAL JUSTICE STEPHEN BREYER.
BEING SHOWN THE DOOR EARLIER
TODAY.
HE DIDN'T MAKE THE ANNOUNCEMENT,
SOMEBODY ELSE LEAKED HIS
RETIREMENT PLAN.
A SHORT TIME LATER THE
WHITE HOUSE PROBABLY CONFIRM
JOE BIDEN STRATEGY TO FILL THE
SPOT.
BIDEN SAID HE WILL MAKE HIS PICK
BASED PURELY ON RACE AND GENDER.
PROMISED ONLY AN
AFRICAN AMERICAN WOMAN WILL BE
SELECTED.
AT JONATHAN TURLEY, A DEMOCRAT,
QUESTIONS THE CONSTITUTIONALITY
OF THIS CRITERIA.
HE BROUGHT THIS, PRECISELY WHAT
THE SUPREME COURT ALREADY
DECLARED TO BE UNCONSTITUTIONAL,
DISCRIMINATION.
WE WILL HAVE MORE OF HIS ARTICLE
COMING UP AND WE WILL BREAK
BIDEN'S POTENTIALLY -- BREAK IT
ALL DOWN.
THE UNLAWFUL AND
UNCONSTITUTIONAL STRATEGY.
BUT FIRST, ANOTHER
GROUNDBREAKING MOMENT AT THE
WHITE HOUSE.
JOE BIDEN ACTION AT A PUBLIC
EVENT.
THAT DID NOT INVOLVE ICE CREAM
BUT UNFORTUNATELY FOR JOE, IT
DIDN'T GO PARTICULARLY WELL.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> I'M ALWAYS TALKING ABOUT
CORVETTES.
I WILL POINT OUT, WHEN I WENT TO
DEARBORN DRIVING NUTS, YOU KNOW,
I WAS UP THERE.
I DON'T KNOW, MAN.
I THINK THE PRESS THAT I WAS
CRAZY.
I ENJOYED IT SO MUCH.
SEEING THE NEW FACTORY.
THAT HOMER.
>> Sean: I DON'T KNOW, MAN.
I DON'T KNOW.
LAST WEEK BIDEN SAID HE HAD NO
IDEA WHY AMERICANS DOUBTED HIS
MENTAL FITNESS.
HE BELIEVES HIS FIRST YEAR IN
OFFICE WAS A TREMENDOUS SUCCESS
AND THAT HE HAS EXCEEDED ALL
EXPECTATIONS FOR THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE, THEY STRONGLY DISAGREE.
LOOK AT THIS NEW POLL THAT HAS
BIDEN'S APPROVAL AT ANOTHER
ALL-TIME LOW.
IN THEIR CASE, 39% PURE THE SAME
POLL SHOWING REPUBLICANS UP BY
EIGHT POINTS ON THE GENERIC
BALLOT HERE AT LAST YEAR THEY
WERE DOWN NINE AND TODAY, ONE
FORMER CLINTON ADVISOR TOLD
AMERICA'S NEWSROOM THAT HE HAS
RARELY EVER SEEN POLL NUMBERS
THIS BAD.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THE PRESIDENT HAS A
DOUBLE-BARRELED PROBLEM.
PEOPLE ARE UPSET THAT THE VIRUS
IS CONTINUING, BUT I THINK IT
EVEN MORE IMPORTANTLY NOW THAT
INFLATION HAS BRIDGED AND
THEREFORE SO FEW PEOPLE THINK
THE ECONOMY IS GOING THE RIGHT
DIRECTION.
AS YOU KNOW, WHEN THINGS ARE
GOING BADLY, THE INNS GET VOTED
OUT.
AND THAT COULD BE A VERY
POWERFUL FORCE HERE.
I'VE RARELY SEEN NUMBERS THIS
BAD IN RECENT TIMES.
>> Sean: MARK PENN IS A
WELL-RESPECTED POLLSTER.
WILL THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION OF
A RECOVER?
FORGET HIS COGNITIVE STRUGGLES
FOR JUST A SECOND.
ANALYSTS NOW PREDICT THAT THE
PRICE OF OIL COULD NOW SOON
SURGED TO $150 A BARREL.
THAT IS A 100% INCREASE.
MAKE NO MISTAKE, JOE BIDEN'S
GREEN NEW SOCIALIST BOSSES AND
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY, THE CULT
OF CLIMATE CHANGE, THEY WANT
THIS TO HAPPEN.
IT'S ALL PART OF THE PLAN.
THEY WANT OIL AND GAS TO BE
EXPENSIVE AND LIMITED.
OBAMA EVEN ONCE HIMSELF ADMITTED
HE WANTED GAS PRICES TO GO UP,
BUT NOT THIS QUICKLY.
AMERICANS WILL SUFFER, INFLATION
WILL SOAR, BUT ACCORDING TO
THEM, IT WILL ALL BE